let's go next to our caller from the six
one four area code caller from six one
four who's this where are you calling
from six one four are you there hello
that's you oh sorry I didn't recognize
the area code
oh is it country code 6000 it's
Australia I gotcha it's country code 61
very oh hi David I'm Angela hi Angela go
ahead what's happening today
I'm calling mainly because of my
overwhelming fear of what my governments
doing and just little things that I've
noticed which I don't think many other
people would notice because only I am
that into it but actually quite alarming
like the amount of funding we've put
aside for natural disasters went from a
hundred and seventy million last year
100 million this year 10 million next
year down to zero by 2020 and at the
moment I think our Environment Minister
probably had I think iron shares in coal
and then our Prime Minister walked
around Parliament House I think last
year honey a love of coals passing it to
be wrong it's only cold it won't hurt
you and yeah it's but I I I encouraged
by the friends on who we should but
we've got the same situation of the
lesser of two evils and I'm yeah I'm
just pretty sure especially I think
they're moving all of the meteorologists
and like people that will be watching
the weather to one centralized place in
Sydney so that's not very helpful for
the rest of the country so thing that
there's so many things that they're
doing which I think will be catastrophic
when it comes to it
added in as much anyone could do about
it except some D corrupting everything
yes
corruption is a big big thing I don't
know too much about the specifics you're
mentioning Angela but I did you have any
question or but it was just that comment
um is that any other way to get through
to your representatives other than the
standard basic ways but especially for
like it's it's a dire it's it's all the
normal stuff it's emailing them calling
them showing up in protesting civil
disobedience general strikes right I
mean it's that the in in countries like
the United States and Australia those
are the things that are available and
then there are people who will go beyond
that into violence I think it's
counterproductive in the long term but
those are those are the options that
that we mostly have to differing degrees
Angela thank you for the call great to
hear from our viewers in Australia this
may be that might have been our first
call from from Australia